okay so uh welcome everyone back uh to
this afternoon session so next talk will
be by Jason Lee uh he is a fellow here
at Simon's and soon he will be a
assistant professor at CMU so Jason Lee
has done a lot of
great works in graph algorithms um and
today he will talk about isolating cut
one of the most beautiful new techniques
uh in recent years that I like a lot
so this talk will be
come as a new tool for Min cut
algorithms and before before I came to
talk I'll give a little disclaimer that
all the results discussed in talk will
be in Aesthetics I think so we will be
we'll make no mention of dynamic records
but as we've seen in previous talks in
this Workshop there's a close connection
between static and dynamic craft
algorithms for example we've seen that
Dynamic arms often use static arms as
like during during the initialization or
as a rebuilding step for example
rebuilding a certain data structure
after some number of certain number of
iterations
and also started algorithms also use
Dynamic arms to speed up each iteration
but uh regardless the focus of this talk
will be not so much the setting itself
but the main tool that I'll be
discussing with this isolating cuts
so let's begin with uh some background
minimum cuts so a cut is a set of edges
who's removed disconnects the graph in
some way
and a minimum cut is a cut of minimum
kernelular weight
and uh the precise definition of minimum
depends on the the particular variant of
minimum cut being studied
in this talk all graphs are undirected
and we can think of
um there it's being uh we either think
of the graph is unweighted with parallel
edges or weighted with non-negative
weights
and finally um
uh so for example in this case
these are valid graphs that we'll be
studying on the other hand we will not
be sending Direct in the stock
so two classic variants of Min cut are
the global Min cut which is just the
minimum weight cut that this needs to
graph in some way
an estimated was a cut that given as
vertices s and t this connects to two
vertices s and t
and one classic result in this area is
that by the maximum cut theorem the St
Maxwell equals the estimate cut
number in particular any an s team and
cut can be solved by running Max flow
and then post processing in linear time
for example in this graph here uh the
following is a global Min cut and here
this is the SD maker for these vertices
smt and note that the St made us not
necessarily the global method
so so in this talk we'll be studying
both the running times of these problems
but also the relationship between how
these problems relate to one another
so here so one uh classic and simple
result is that there's a global mean
that can be solved using many SC maker
calls
and here's here's the algorithm so let's
fix any s to be any arbitrary vertex and
just find the SD main Cuts over all
other vertices t
and report as small as of least cost as
a global main cut
and note that
um because there must be a Vertex t on
the opposite side of the global Min cut
we'll we will recover the correct Global
Min cut and this is an algorithm that
solves Global men cut in N minus one
calls to St Min cut or equivalently to
SD Maxwell
so um this is a brief like landscape of
the the historic history of global Min
cut so first we have an album running n
minus 1 Max flows and then there's been
since then there's been specialized
algorithms for Global Min cut that for
example in this in these Works they they
figure out a ways to run Max flow uh
quickly uh this they figure out ways to
speed up the max flows on each iteration
and and then later on there's been
um more uh faster improvements that run
uh independent of any maximum calls and
finally a class of resolved carger
showed that there is a near linear time
randomized algorithm to solve this
problem independent of any maximums
so one um famous open problem that
Carter Post in his uh randomized
government cut work is coming up in a
deterministic to match the
um to match the randomized running time
but in particular what's interesting is
at that time even for Max flow it was
not known whether
um determines a global mind cutter can
read one and can be solved in determines
in Maxwell time
so recently um there's been some
exciting progress in this area one
classic result which recently won the
Falcon focus in price is a deterministic
global Min cut can be solved in nearly
new time for simple graphs these are
graphs that are unweighted with no
parallel edges between vertices
this result has been improved and
has been viewed in different
perspectives but again these were simple
graphs
and one result I will talk will be
studying this talk is that we showed the
work with myself and demonic panography
we showed that there's a determination
of global men cut that runs in poly log
Mass locals
subsequently this um a work by myself
has improved the running time
deterministic Global Min cut all the way
to almost linear
which matches the best best running
randomized this should have been n to
the one for zero one
um but for in but the techniques are
quite different and we'll mainly focus
on the result
foreign
idea I want to study in this talk is the
notion of isolating cuts
formally
um to motivate the the notion of
isolating Cuts let's first let's revisit
the simple Min cut elements from before
where we just um fix a Vertex s and
iterate of all other vertices t
and note that
um really all we need from this
algorithm is to find another vertex t on
the opposite side of the global income
if we can find such a Vertex T then we
have we have the global netcut
and then the the high level question we
want to ask is how do we efficiently
find two vertices on opposite sides of
equivalent code
so here's one uh one simple observation
suppose that we're also promised that
the makeup is balanced and let's say
it's either it's in the in the most
balanced way possible there's exactly n
over two vertices on either side
then we can just do random sampling
procedure where the sample two versus
SNT and with probably half there will be
an opposite size of the main cuts
and and if that were true then we would
recover the global Min cut
and we can just repeat his login times
to succeed with high probability
so in other words if the makeup was
balanced if there were linear number of
release on each side then then we can
solve this easily in log n many columns
of course on the may not be balanced
there could be let's say k vertices on
the on the smaller side where K is much
smaller than n
and here one thing we could do is
suppose we sample instead with rate one
over K where K might be much smaller
than n
then when cos and probably we still
sample exactly one vertex on the smaller
side
and once again we can repeat this login
times to sample exactly one vertex with
high probability on some iteration
and finally we can get rid of this um
this uh we can always guess K by
doubling so that's not an issue but of
course the issue is we might we may
sample many vertices on the larger side
and this is exactly what the isolating
cost problem will try to
so let's uh more formally Define the
problem
so suppose as the smaller type of Min
cut and we obtain a subset of vertices T
the sample set such as exactly one
vertex on the smaller side is in t
foreign
we want to solve is given the setting
we're defined for any vertex T in our
sample set of terminals a minimum cut
that separates T from the rest of the
vertices so think of
um think of it you can think of it two
ways you think of this this cut as
isolating the vertex T from the rest of
the vertices
or we can think of Contracting the rest
of the vertices into single super vertex
and just running as the income
and the catchers we want to we want to
Output this cut such a cut for every
single vertex T in our in our terminal
so we call this Iceland gospel so for
example in this diagram here for this
green Terminal D here
um the following cut is a is a valid
isolating cut for this terminal but of
course we want to find the icing cuts
for the other terms as well
any questions about the definition of
the problem
so we call this problem isolating Cuts
problem and of course one naive solution
to solving this problem is by simply
once again Contracting all the other
Terminals and do super vertices finding
the assignment doing this for every
terminal T this takes the size of T many
Maxwell calls but of course the size of
the terminals can be largest n
and the key element which we will show
we will prove in this in this talk is
what we call it the Iceland cutslama is
that the Iceland custom can be solved
much faster there can be solving just
log of n many minus
so before I I cover the isolating Cuts
algorithm and it's proof let's first
discuss how the Iceland Cuts immediately
implies a simple randomized Global Mecha
dog
and here the key additional degree in it
is just simple random sampling as we
discussed before let's sample let's kind
of guess the the by doubling the value
of K that we want more more precisely
let's iterate over let's say log n
levels of I and sample each vertex one
over with probably one over two to the I
and for that's that this terminal let
the sample Breeze be the terminal set T
and we'll just repeat this log in times
to substitute high probability
and then we'll run isolating cuts on
each iteration and return a smallest cut
ever found
so the court is actually very simple
if we take the correct iteration I
then with with constant probability on
each iteration we sample we succeed with
constant probability that we sample
exactly one vertex on on the smaller
side
and
um the Iceland customer will return a
valid main cut for that terminal and
since we just we look at all the cuts
found overall iterations we will indeed
recover the global Min cut and finally
what about the other Cuts we find well
they're all valid graph Cuts they're all
valid Cuts in the graph so they can only
be larger so taking a global minimum
will indeed recover the correct goal of
income
the running time is available we will be
dominated by uh poly log calls to
Iceland Cuts Lama plus some near linear
time post-processing
and therefore it run and we will show
that the isolating Cuts can be solved in
poly log Max flows and therefore the
entire album will run in polyline
Maxwell
so let's um
next let's let's uh see how the Iceland
customers proved
exactly
so um
hold on
it's not showing it on the other screen
it's a key idea for the minimize playing
Cuts is that we want to First compute
and uh so so here's a setting I'm here
for convenience we'll we'll rename the
terminal set to be R think of us like
the red vertices in the graph
and let's say SV is the
the isolating cut for the for each red
terminal V
um and the the first idea is you want to
compute an upper Bound for each
isolating cut so so we want to find
these Cuts these subsets C of E which
include each SV so hv's SV is the the
set of vertices on the on the smaller on
the side of the isolating cut that
contains the isolated vertex
I'm going to find an upper bound kind of
C of E that contains SV
and we also want the CV to be disjoint
to be vertex destroyed so it's the first
step of the algorithm
and to see why this suffices
um for each CB let's imagine Contracting
everything outside CV to single vertex
and then T and then just running the the
the Min Cut St Min cut between the
isolate the terminals and T
and because CV is an upper bound
this will still recover the correct
estimate code
now what is the running time of all
these esteem calls note that because the
set the sets CV are disjoint
each Edge in the original graph is a
most uh two such graphs contracted
graphs
in the worst case and that is between
two different CV
and if we contract the the outside for
each of the these graphs it will belong
in those two graphs but it will not
belong in any other graph once you
contract
so therefore the total size of all the
all the graphs of the contracted graphs
on which we run SD Min cut is just
almost 2m
and therefore um the total size of the
grass on which would run Max low is also
at most a 2m
and
and you can kind of like fold all these
uh
um graphs into a single Maxwell call on
um on a linear number of vertices
measures
so that's the first step of the
algorithm
and let's see how we can construct these
upper bounds for each isolating cuts
so the first step is uh suppose uh
suppose
um
we compute a set of bipartitions of the
terminals
such that each pair of terminals is
severed by at least one of them
so so one easy way that you you can see
it is possible is if we just randomly
partition the terminals into two sets
then with half probability for any given
pair S and T they'll belong to a
different size and if you repeat this
like log of R many times with high
probability we will um there'll be one
partition that separates uh SNP hsnt
but of course um there's also like the
termination ways to do this for example
by looking at the bind like taking a
binary representation of each vertex and
going over the base of the binders
um I uh that's a bit are we a bit
technical or I won't I'll skip this in
the park
and then for each so so in this example
suppose these red vertices are the four
terminals then the following two by
partitions indeed separate every single
pair S and T
then for each pair uh for each by
partition will cut will will compute the
Min cut separating the two sides of
bipartition
so for example for this by partition we
can we can compute this cut here
and for this one we can compute this
card here
the next the claim is that if we take
the Union
of all the Min Cuts we ever found this
separates all of R in a sense that if if
we delete the union of all these edges
and all these Min cuts
then every single a terminal vertex will
be separated from all the others and
this is simply because for any two
vertices in the graph there exists some
bipartition that separates these two
and the corresponding Min cut will
separate those two vertices and since we
take a union of all the Min Cuts this
will indeed separate all the produces
and now the key claim
um is that if we remove all the the
union of the edges of the cuts
then if we look at for each terminal the
kinetic component containing that
terminal then it kind of contains the
the isolating card so here I think the
green cut is nicely and cut the upper
the the kind of upper bound we we obtain
is the is the kinetic component
containing this vertex and we'll show
that
um this component kind of contains
uh the correct isolating current
and the probability bias is by a simple
um application of Sub sub modularity of
cuts also known as uncrossing
if you look at this is the bipartition
cut
and this is the
supposed contradiction
that the correct Iceland cut kind of
went beyond
um the the component here
then
um by uncrossing these two cuts we get
these two cuts and uh by the the the the
sub modularity of cuts shows that if we
uncross the sum of the two cuts can be
at most the original two cuts
and then next notice that this uncross
cut here
is still a valid
um cut between these bipartitions so
this value here is a most so the this
cell here is at least the initial Min
cut between this bipartition
and to remove these two from the
equation we get that the uncrossed cut
here is on most the the original
estimate cut and therefore we could have
replaced this cut here right this cut
here because it's also an isolating cut
minimize the income
so we can kind of do this um until we
find a nice lean cut that does not cross
any of the
any questions about this
so that concludes the
um
I think I'm just
um missing something like
you're saying that we find the
this is an algorithmic thing or an
analytic thing when you're saying that
you can have an if you have an isolating
cut that sort of goes too far you can
replace it with an equally good
isolating concrete it doesn't go too far
is that an algorithmic thing right
um so you can think of as algorithm
proof or you kind of replace it each
time so this is purely for an approved
setting so we're trying to prove that
this upper bound number
so it's one way you can think of it as
you can just kind of iteratively replace
algorithm and replace Cuts until they
don't cross anymore or you can also
think of us take the like inclusion wise
minimal
cut and by conjunction and assume for
contradiction it crosses over and get a
contribution this way okay I think my
confusion was that your algorithm
doesn't know what the
um isolating card is but this is all
just to prove a
structural theorem
someone more precisely um
the upper bound
uh this up around here is really like
we're kind of assuming that these SV
cuts are inclusion wise minimum
and therefore they must be contained
so that kind of concludes the Iceland
Cuts lemon
and recall that this immediately implies
a very simple randomized Global midcode
algorithm
which runs in if you collect all log
factors it runs in log Cube and many has
C maximums
so this this algorithm analysis is
actually very simple it's two pages
and with this and we discovered this
back in like 2020 or so
and since like since the the arm is so
simple and it um it implies such a
natural result that Global main cut can
be reduced to poly log estimate cuts and
since this real was not even known
before
um we thought we were like we had
something special going on like we
thought we really had a brand new idea
that had potential to be uh developed in
the future
at the same time we realized that
um the concrete result here Global Min
cut in polylog Max flows does not imply
anything new
because Carter already solved Global
Minka 20 years ago he showed a
randomized global makeup algorithm in
near linear time which is even faster
than even the current best Maxwell
so unfortunately we found it hard to
sell this real result in this way and
instead the way we sold our result
was we showed that you can de-randomize
this entire procedure so in particular
you can de-randomize this this vertex
sampling here and the Iceland Cuts level
is also deterministic you can do the
bipartitioning deterministically
and the final result we we showed in our
first paper was a deterministic Min cut
in polylog Maxwells and this indeed did
improve upon the previous best program
and the new tools we kind of um the new
tools we added in this work
um are pretty standard tools such as
color coding determines the
specification experiment decomposition
but in spirit the main like technical
the main conceptual contribution of this
work really was the simple Global Min
code reduction
and and in particular the idea of
isolating cuts
any questions
is the runtime of the deterministic
reduction near linear almost linear a
good question it's actually almost
linear at the time at the time
um Maxwell wasn't even almost an year so
we can kind of like kind of like sell as
near linear but um assuming uh near
linear Max flow it's it's almost
is that still open if like you can
improve that overhead
good question it's still open
um but we I have ongoing work trying to
trying to improve
thank you
so
um this the first row was nice but in
spirit like the the what uh the
the real um contribution of this work
was a simple Google in particular
isolating cuts so that gave us hope that
in perhaps Iceland guys can be applied
to much a much more broader set of main
cutoff rooms and that's indeed what we
found
so in subsequent work we showed that
icelain cuts also um we can also play
icing cuts to solve faster vertex
connectivity this is um instead of
removing edges from graph we want to
remove vertices from a graph with this
one correct and we showed that uh with
uh nanakai
we showed that a Vertex connectivity can
be solved in polylog Maxwell Maxwells
which is by the recent breakthrough of
Maxwell almost in your time and this was
the first uh Improvement uh
another result we showed was um if you
consider the more General Steiner
connected problem which is giving a set
of terminals finding the Min cut that
separates that set of terminals we
showed that in the same work essentially
by the same Construction
can also be solved in polylog Maxwells
and what's interesting about this this
problem was that there was no previous
non-trivial algorithm for this problem
so in the most General weighted craft
setting the previous best uh result was
just uh the linear Max flows
so we kind of had the first non-trivial
item that's also optimal
it was also very soon
um more more recently we've also managed
to apply Iceland cuts to various forms
of connectivity augmentation
there's a problem of finding a minimum
wage set of edges to make a graph a tile
connected for its own value Tau this
means that we want to we want the mini
cut of the augmented graph to be at
least tell
and the first result was we showed that
through isolating Cuts we can solve this
problem using polyog Maxwells
and since then we further improve it to
near linear time independent Maxwell and
also
finally in other work that's on my own
um Iceland Cuts has been improved has
been extended to more general settings
for example hypergraphs a symmetry some
other functions
and and so on
so but the story of icingus doesn't
any next week we study more General
variants of mid-cut in particular
problems that require us to find
multiple main cuts
so two classic uh problems in this area
are the single Source spin cut which
requires finding uh which is given a
source vertex s find the SC Min cuts to
all other vertices t
and even more generally the all pairs
make our problem we're going to find the
main cuts for all pairs of our us
um and note that on the single Source
method algorithm naturally reduces to n
minus one calls to maximums by simply
iterating over all T and running them as
unless a classic a non-trivial result is
that even all Paris men can be reduced
and mice on Maxwells and this is by a
classroom who they show the all-purism
in cuttings can also be reused in mice
and Maxwell's this is non-trivial
because the trivial algorithm will
require n squaring
the bottom line is of single Source
making all pairs makeup are can both
resolved using n minus one minuses this
was the state of the art before I worked
so here's like a kind of a diagram of
the current landscape uh the landscape
of
income problems at the very top we have
the hardest problem all pair has been
cut which can be solved in N minus one
Max flows this reduces two
um an easier problem a single Source
band cut
and an even easier problem standerman
cut
and by this recent work here we showed a
standard maker can is equivalent of the
poly lock factors to estimate cut
and final Loop here we have Global Min
cut using in nearly near the near Time
by Karger independent of any maximums
a recent work in this area showed the
following equivalents that uh all pairs
is actually equivalent up to polylog
factors to single enforcement
so in other words
um
to in other words to improve on all
pairs mankind it suffices to improve on
xenos Horseman
so at this point know that there's kind
of like two classes of results here the
two classes of problems the first class
will all require like linear number of
Max flows
and the second class here we all require
poly lock Max flows and of course
there's also a result here that in
carcinoma
and what's what's interesting about
um about these uh single source and all
pairs but uh Maxwell problems is that
more than 60 years later these Remain
the fastest animals for these problems
and does not do lack of trying and um in
in recent years there's been fast almost
for special cases of these problems for
example on a way to graph simple graphs
and various forms uh various research
families
nothing was known prior to our work even
for approximate variance of these
problems so if you want to allow let's
say one percent approximations for
singles resolved pairs the best thing
you could do was
um
run n minus 1 approximate maximums
so the first rule in this area is we
showed that
um we gave an algorithm for one plus
answer approximate all perishment Cuts
using just poly lock calls to the
Iceland customer
and this required poly lock force in
turn that requires pilot calls the exact
Max flow which is almost in your
timeline
so one thing uh one caveat in this
result was that
um in order to solve approximate
um all pair of spinning costs we
actually required um calls to isak Max
flow since then this has been um cleaned
up in the sense that
it surprises to solve a form of
approximate Max flow
and this can be solve a near linear time
not just almost linear and this is
associated subsequent work
but of course
um
the the result of exactly all pairs Mayo
still remain open until subsequent work
where the the two groups of um the two
the two all Paris been cut groups who
are working together we kind of banded
together and we showed that actually
um all pairs make up problem or more
precisely the karma Hillary problem can
be improved for the first time in 60
years
which the first of all in this area
which um for in the first real in this
area we showed that a quadratic times
devices
and indeed we did follow the the recipe
of single Source main cut we reduced to
single Source Min cut and show that this
problem can be solved in score time
here's like a brief high level overview
of how we told this we first used black
box Black Box used the approximate all
appearance algorithm plus if we iterate
overall powers of one plus Epsilon then
we show that we can reduce this problem
to the case or we have a terminal set T
and we want to Output the STM in cuts
um and we want to Output an estimate
that's given the promise that all the
correct values are within let's say a
one plus Epsilon Factor
so can we kind of reduce this problem by
kind of iterating over all powers of one
potential
and in other words our new goal is given
the promise that the correct values are
all within one plus absolutely about
each other I'll put the exact counties
this turned out to be not trivial
and here's a brief overview of how we
did it we kind of use
known as Steiner tree packing this is
like a generation of if you're familiar
with cargers um near linear time in cut
out and he used uh spanning tree packing
and kind of uh we use a standard variant
of this we pack steinistries instead and
by using this key property that all the
correct the Min cut values are within
weapons on each other we can show that
we can pack enough Steiner trees such a
random randomly chosener tree
um crosses the Min cut in almost four
edges oh no
and here the Main Ingredients were
classification this multiple multiple
multiplicative weight method uh weight
update method that we've seen in
previous talks in this Workshop
and also like because Steiner trees
itself NP hard we resorted we um
we instead use it on approximate
statutory algorithm and this one in
particular was very useful
next we would sample along
to reduce our sample size and still
preserve the fact that on average or
with high probably at least one of these
signatories is there sex the cut in
almost four edges
and finally we showed that we showed an
algorithm to compute the estimate cut
assuming that there's almost four edges
crossing the four edges of the standard
reprocess code
and here the key part of you we used is
that here are the key ingredients we
used was the Iceland customer and also
like various um techniques on foreign
so first up here takes n Square time
because we're running multi-weight
update on the sparse fire containing n
edges we might as well sparse the graph
first because
um all chords are preserved out to one
plus Epsilon
and
um it's known that there's a formula
with independent multi-weight update
that that runs in in iterations number
of edges in the graph
and the Second Step here is dominated by
calls to isolating customer
and therefore total running time was
polylog Max flows plus an additional N
squared right
so subsequently
um uh in a paper that will appear in
this box
we sped up the the standard tree packing
using uh Advanced Dynamic data
structures for example the robust core
data structure Aaron printing
and indeed this hour is now basically on
your optimal because we can use the the
Breakthrough is all of these act Maxwell
novels in your time to get a garment
Hood tree and almost in here
so basically um
you kind of have a satisfying conclusion
of all these main problems we show that
all these makeup problems at least the
study discussed in uh including the
hardest variant can all be solved in
almost
foreign
so all of this is one plus Epsilon
so all these Act
I think
the question was um are all these
results Epsilon turns out all these
results do um hold free exact setting
but for the garma hill tree or all pairs
to make our problem in particular we use
approximate one plus Epsilon as a like a
black box build um step towards getting
the exactly
so in the final slide I want to discuss
um future directions
um for makeup problems and the most
indirect interrogen is directed graphs
and
sort of another the first natural step
because we we tried was was trying to
generalize isolating cuts to direct
drops
but unfortunately there is one issue
which is that Iceland customer if you
look at the proof of why it works it
requires both someone real sub
modularity and symmetry of the cut
function
for director graphs we have some
modularity but you don't have symmetry
ultimately uh for any given cut the
edges the director is going from one
side to the other is not necessarily the
same as that is going from the other
side
and actually turns out if we play around
the definition we can actually achieve
symmetry but then break some modularity
so it turns out like we don't have a
definition of um for directed grass that
she's both these properties that are
that um are necessary to get Iceland
customer
and this stuff this difficulty of direct
graphs has indeed be seen in literature
for example in historically Min cut
elements within digraphs have
um trailed behind under Buffs so
recently the best running line was still
MN
and in recent work we have some partial
Improvement where we showed that the
recommend that can be solved in just
square root and Maxwell's
but of course there's not does not seem
like the right algorithm it turns out
like
um they're they're feel like there's
still some stock in this argument but we
don't know how to improve it further
and I leave as an open problem can we
get direction been cut
[Music]
[Applause]
questions for Jason
okay
yeah so Leah and panagrahi claim that
this can for at least Steiner trees you
know be extended to hypergraph Cuts is
that something that you think that
actually follows entrepreneurs
[Music]
um
so it does indeed uh it's in hyberg
quest for example um Global hypergraph
Min cut can also be solved in polyblock
Maxwells but this is not a result that
we observed this was by Chandra jakaria
and Ken Conrad they observed that um
more generally for some modular for any
symmetrical modular function which
includes hypercraft Cuts you can solve
in
padlock Maxwell's or
um instead of Max flow some kind of like
symmetric uh some other questions
asymmetric function minimization all
right right yes
yes
so does this real this result here
um
can you explain what a directed cut is
and what we're trying to do in the
directed case because I failed to
understand what's the difference with
the undirected okay so forth Direct
better cut the it's not symmetric on
with on two sides so for example one
concrete way to define this find a
Vertex at s such that uh the to minimize
find a Vertex set as of course not the
entire set and not empty set
such that to minimize the number of
directed edges going out of us
but you don't care about that just going
inside us
so for example the graph has the
strongly connected if the in order for
the make it to be not zero
X
if I assume that the Mac flow is like
linear time strongly polynomial time
then will you get everything in linear
time strongly that's a very good
question
um so for the first few result
so for the see so this result yes
um bird is coming out of course
um only works for unweighted graphs like
this this is a setting where the
vertices have are unweighted universes
weight one
we don't know how to make this work for
all waiting
um I believe this result here does do
some scaling approach so it's not quite
strong
um I might be wrong
this result here
um I believe is also independent
Skilling you just third who you play how
about like right in Garmin who tree so
we so our current algorithm does use
some scaling
um does use
it does enter the overall powers of what
conceptualon so it's not strongly a
polynomial but we suspect that this can
be made from we just um we haven't
worked for Donald details okay thank you
a question
all right then let's thank Jason thank
you
[Applause]
so we have a break for